mais d'abord on revient donc sur
l'annonce de la candidature de Jean
Gérard pommier aux prochaines
sénatoriales l'actuelle président du
conseil départemental d'Indre-et-Loire a
décidé de se présenter à l'élection du
24 septembre prochain une candidature
sous les couleurs de la droite et de son
parti les républicains explications et
analyse avec Sarah gros et Florent
Clavel
cette fois c'est la bonne après avoir
renoncé en 2017 Jean-Gérard pommier est
bien candidat aux prochaines élections
sénatoriales une décision qu'il a prise
il y a deux mois pour convaincre les
1537 grands électeurs de voter pour lui
l'ancien maire de Saint-Avertin met en
avant sa longue expérience d'élue locale
et notamment ses 7 ans de présidence du
conseil départemental d'Indre-et-Loire
un mandat pendant lequel il a eu de 16
d'interpeller l'État pour défendre les
intérêts de sa collectivité de quoi lui
donner des idées si l'accède au Palais
du Luxembourg ce qui est très important
c'est de faire évoluer la relation que
l'État a avec les collectivités locales
qui n'est pas marquée par la confiance
que je souhaiterais et je pense qu'il
faut améliorer cela et rendre plus plus
de pouvoir en collectivités locales avec
de meilleurs ressources soutenu
officiellement par le président et l'air
du Sénat Gérard Larcher Jean Gérard
pommier restant revanche discret pour
l'instant sur ses colistiers seul
exception l'identité de sa suivante de
liste et alliés de poids au département
il s'agit de l'actuel sénatrice
d'Indre-et-Loire Isabelle Raymond
paveyron j'ai été stoppé pendant
quelques mois pour des raisons de santé
mais je n'ai jamais envisagé de me
retirer de mes fonctions sénatoriales
comme je vous le dis c'est un travail
discret c'est un travail de fond que
j'effectue la défense et la raison de
l'état Jean Gérard pommier trouvera face
à lui le son triste Vincent Louault mais
aussi pierrelain roaron à gauche s'il
est élu il devra laisser son siège de
président du conseil départemental avec
une nouvelle élection à la clé